dans moins d'une heure nous allons voter
pour ou contre la ratification du ceta
au cours des dix heures de débats
mercredi dernier nous avons été nombreux
sur sebha a dénoncé les méfaits de cet
accord désastreux sur le plan sanitaire
désastreux sur le plan environnemental
désastreux pour nos éleveurs
malgré nos arguments malgré l'avis de la
commission d'experts indépendants vous
rester arc bouté sur vos positions
éleveurs moi même je suis élu d'un
département ou sans élevage
il n'y aura pas de ménagement de
cohésion territoriale un département où
les éleveurs broadys des viandes
d'excellence tout en entretenant des
paysages et en agissant correct marc e
pour le climat grâce au carbone qu'ils
stockent dans leurs prairies vos portes
et aux éleveurs avec la ratification du
ck c'est à part dont un coup dur un coup
fatal et vous fait et vous le faites
avec mépris
vous ne les écoutez pas pire pire vous
leur mettez tout quand vous montez au
français et aux consommateurs dans un
état de droit il revient à l'état
d'assurer le respect des lois de la
république et la sécurité de chacun de
nos concitoyens sur tout le territoire
national
en tout temps et en toutes circonstances
après près de neuf mois où le rendez
vous hebdomadaire des français était de
20 heures du samedi soir pour connaître
l'étendue des dégâts occasionnés par les
gilet jaune
certains ont vite compris qu'ils
pouvaient insulté cassé pillé profané
voire agresser dans la plus totale
totale impunité
il n'est pas acceptable que dans notre
démocratie
les voyous attaquent et détruisent et
symbole de notre république
persuadé s'ils sont identifiés de s'en
sortir avec une simple relaxe jean paul
delevoye votre envoyé spécial pour les
retraites a rendu sa copie la semaine
dernière après dix-huit mois de
concertation qui ont plutôt pris des
airs de câlinothérapie il a remis ses
préconisations et il a réussi force est
de constater à nous présenter ce projet
dans un beau papier cadeau lorsqu'on
étudie ce document une première fois on
ne peut qu'adhérer un système plus
simple un régime universel
elles mêmes droits pour tous cela est
une bonne chose mais cela n'est en rien
nouveau car la droite et le centre le
préconisait déjà en 2010 par la réforme
de notre collègue eric woerth
l'analyse change lorsque l'on gratte un
peu ce rapport inquiète l application de
la réforme restent particulièrement
floues et incertaine la question n'est
pas ce que dit le rapport
mais plus précisément ce qu'il ne dit
pas il a été annoncé la fin des régimes
spéciaux allez vous réellement monsieur
le premier ministre
supprimer leur avantage votre majorité
avait annoncé qu'à régime universel ne
signifiait pas un régime unique
qu'en sera-t-il réellement
l'augmentation de la pension minimale à
85% est également une bonne chose
notamment pour nos retraités agricoles
mais comment allez vous financer cela
alors que vous promettez une enveloppe
constante
s'il ya des gagnants il y aura forcément
des perdants et je pense par exemple aux
fonctionnaires aux cadres aux familles
qui seront les perdants
quel sort sera réservé aux pensions de
réversion enfin l'hypocrisie
l'hypocrisie sur l'âge de départ
le président de la république annonçait
le 25 avril dernier qu'il était
nécessaire de travailler davantage et
avec votre immuable en même temps vous
maintenez l'âge légal à 62 ans tout en
instaurant un âge pivot à 64 ans cela ne
paraît pas très sérieux et créera
rapidement de fortes disparités
sans compter surtout une baisse des
pensions monsieur prix ministre beaucoup
de flou subsiste dans vos intentions sur
la fixation du poing sur la transition
entre les deux régimes au mois de
juillet 2017 vous assuriez monsieur le
premier ministre dans votre discours de
politique générale que le gouvernement
tiendrait la promesse du candidat
emmanuel macron de créer quinze mille
places supplémentaires de prison
mais ça c'était avant et c'est bien
dommage car l'engagement des 15000
places étaient réellement une priorité
de sécurité publique et nécessité
absolue
comme le rappelle régulièrement la
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté a dit nasa la loi
de programmation 2018-2022 de madame la
garde des sceaux ne prévoyait plus que
7000 places supplémentaires
or il semble aujourd'hui que ce chiffre
ne sera pas atteint en effet dans le
rapport au parlement sur l'orientation
budgétaire le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer la révision à la baisse des
crédits du ministère de la justice
remettant ainsi en cause la trajectoire
adopté il ya cinq mois à peine et qu'ici
au sénat nous avions déjà jugé
insuffisant 2% madame la ministre
2 % c'est la part du solaire dans notre
production électrique 2%
c'est le signe d'un échec celui de
l'ambition solaire française et je ne
parle même pas de l'auto ce consommation
électrique qui ne se développe pas dans
notre pays madame la ministre nous
partageons une vive inquiétude quant aux
changements climatiques
notre chance est double améliorer
l'efficience de la consommation
énergétique en isolant les plats soir
thermique par exemple remplacer lorsque
cela est possible les énergies fossiles
par de l'électricité décarbonée le
gouvernement a en effet décidé de nous
demander aucun effort aux intermittents
du spectacle qui ne seront pas concernés
par la réforme de l'assurance chômage en
2010 est l'indemnisation et
l'accompagnement dans l'emploi de 120000
intermittents ont coûté 1 milliard droit
pour seulement 367 millions de recettes
soit un déficit d'un milliard d'euros
les intermittents sont donc largement
bénéficiaires de l'assurance chômage
madame la ministre après la colère des
gilet jaune
les français demandent que les réformes
soient équitables et mises en oeuvre
dans un esprit de justice tu tout le
monde devrait contribuer à cette réforme
ce sont les salariés via la csg et les
cotisations chômage qui financent
majoritairement le fonctionnement du
service public de l'emploi
pour quelles raisons les intermittents
du spectacle reste-t-il intouchable est
épargné par cette réponse
[Musique]